[Music]
at the time that it happened my sister
and i were walking to maragville which
is a predominantly asian neighborhood we
decided to opt
not to drive
we reached an intersection and then we
heard two girls kind of talking really
loudly behind us she was wearing grey
track pants and her hair was up in this
bun when she started like approaching us
her aura was a lot more obvious to me my
thoughts were to just
like maybe ignore it and let it go
but then it was the comment that kind of
set my sister and i off
one of the girls she walked past us and
said stay away from them they've got
coronavirus
i looked at my sister and we both
responded at the same time
i feel like there's definitely a
stereotype against asian people we're
not supposed to retaliate we're just
supposed to stand there take whatever
comes to us i definitely think she was
trying to
make us feel really small
and
just basing it off
how we look
she thought she had power over us it
obviously struck a nerve in sophie and i
and we immediately yelled back and said
like excuse me what did you just say
after me and my sister responded
it took one of the girls back because i
think she was expecting us to not be
able to speak english that's when things
kind of
blew up and
that's when she started becoming a lot
more
aggressive
the first thing the girl in the grey
said to us was go back to china you
asian dog right after
we heard those words she started to
walk closer to us
at that point i tried to kind of
de-escalate the situation she walked
away maybe like 10 or 20 meters across
the street then she ran back i'd like to
talk about my camera and i think the
camera is what made her like really
really upset really really aggravated
and then she said that she had a knife
on her don't do it i don't know that you
wanna
you asian dog yeah yeah
yeah get the [ __ ] out of me now i was
still filming her at that point i was
like zooming in on her because i wanted
to try get like her face and like just
her body in general in the video so that
when i showed police they could try to
identify her
[Music]
a man comes in and intervenes at that
point finally even though he created
that barrier she still was able to like
step a little bit further away
and then she spat
[Music]
her spit got in my left eye and my hair
like this side of my face here i felt
angry i felt humiliated as well i
thought about everyone else looking and
i was
like
worried about what sophie would think as
well
the girl in gray choosing to spit on
rosa rather than hit her i think
definitely speaks to
her wanting to feel like important like
i'm powerful and
you know you're you're nothing
like i you're so
unimportant that
i could spit on you and not there's
nothing you could do about it
and when i calmed down a bit and i
understood what happened
i just cried it's the only thing that i
could do to like express how i felt i
feel like it changed me in a way that
like i know i'm not
a victim i see us now as advocates for
change me coming forward and talking
about it has helped people it's
definitely showed them that it's okay to
come out and talk about this stuff it's
your right
[Music]